ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول اختيار حسم
به سياسي سينانوغان موقفه بدعم مرشح
التحالف رجب طيب اردوغان في الجوله
الثانيه من انتخابات الرئاسه المقرره بعد
ايام قليله والتي يتنافس فيها اردوغان مع
مرشحي تحالف المعارضه كما الكلتشدار
اوغلوغان اقصى في الجوله الاولى
للانتخابات الرئاسيه او اقسيه عندما ترشح
عن تحالف الاجداد بعد حصوله على نسبه 5.2%
من الاصوات هذه النسبه سلطت الضوء على ما
وصف بالدور المركزي الذي سيلعبه قبل
انطلاق السباق الحاسم بين المرشحين
اردوغان وكليتشار اوغلو وكان شدد على
مطلبي ترحيل ملايين المهاجرين غير شرعيين
من تركيا وفق جدول زمني وكذلك الاستمرار
كما قال في محاربتي كل الجماعات الارهابيه
من جهته نفى اردوغان في تصريحات تلفزيونيه
حدوث اي مساومه مع اوغان او وجوده شرط
بحصول الاخير على منصب الحكومه في الحكومه
الجديده في حال الفوز في الانتخابات فيما
اكد هوجان خلال مؤتمر الصحفي على اهميه ان
يخضع البرلمان والرئيس لنفسي اداره
التحالف متهما المعارضه بالفشل في تامين
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه وفقدي عامل الاستقرار
وفق قوله من جهته اكد رئيس حزب النصر
امنيه اوزداج ان موقف اوغان لا يمثل حزبه
واصفا قراره اوغان بالشخصي
سجلنا اعلن اننا سندعم السيد رجب طيب
اردوغان مرشح الرئاسه عن تحالف الشعب في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات ادعو كل
الناخبين الذين صوتوا لنا في الجوله
الاولى لدعم السيد اردوغان في جوله
الاعاده فشل تحالف الامه في تحقيق النجاح
الكافي ضد تحالف الشعب الذي يتولى السلطه
منذ 20 عاما كما انهم لم يتمكنوا من تقديم
منظور يقنعنا بالمستقبل والاهم انهم فشلوا
في تامين الاغلبيه البرلمانيه وتجاهلت
عامل الاستقرار
يدعم اردوغان
قبل جوله الاعاده بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
رجب طيب اردوغان التقى سنان اوغان
اردوغان اكد في تصريحات سابقه انه لن يخضع
امام مطالب اوغان واكد ايضا انه لا يتفق
معه في الترحيل الشامل للاجئين
مشددا على ان الشعب هو صانع الملوك
المعارضه التركيه علقت على خطوه اوغان
وتاييده الاردوغان
مرشح المعارضه كمال كالجدار اوغلو غرد على
تويتر قائلا لقد بات واضحا من يقف بجانب
تركيا ومن يقف بجانب بيعها
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
رئيس تحرير تركيا ومن اسطنبول تقعدا وجلوى
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام الى نقاش ملفنا الاول واسمحوا لي
ان ابدا مع الاستاذ زاهد سيد زاهد في
الواقع موضوع اللاجئين والوضع الانساني
عموما يقول البعض بانه من اصعب الازمات
التي مرت بها سوريا هي الازمه الحاليه قد
تكون الازمه الاصعب في تاريخها الحديث
وهذه الازمه انسحبت كذلك على تركيا بما ان
تركيا استقبلت الملايين من اللاجئين ولكن
موضوع اللجوء في تركيا يبقى محط انظار
كثيرين ويمثل نقطه استفهام كبيره ويبدو
بانه ملف تلعب به الايدي السياسيه حتى
اردوغان يقول شيء ويتراجع عنه من فتره الى
اخرى ما الذي يمثله هذا الملف بالتحديد
بين القاده والمرشحين الى الرئاسه
والمرشحين
بدايه التحيه الطيبه لك ولجميع المشاهدين
قناتكم ولضيفكم الكريم يعني لا شك ان
موضوعه اللاجئين بشكل عام هو مثار جدل
دعنا لنقل بين السياسيين انفسهم
وكان هناك خطاب لدى حزب العداله والتنميه
التقليدي كما عرف بخطاب المهاجرين
والانصار وما شابه ذلك من الخطابات التي
ترحب بجميع اللاجئين من جميع الدول
والتعاون الذي حصل بين تركيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي والاتفاقيه التي وقعت بين تركيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي التي من خلالها ايضا
تركيا ضمنت الى حد كبير العديد من المكاسب
الاقتصاديه والماديه والسياسيه ايضا لكن
هناك شيئا ما تغير دعنا نقول قبل خمس
سنوات بشكل واضح في خطاب حزب العداله
والتنميه او في او في
تقييم حزب العداله والتنميه نفسه قبل كل
شيء المساله هو انه حزب العداله والتنميه
قبل نحو خمس سنوات خسر الانتخابات المحليه
البلديه في المدن الكبرى ولا سيما اسطنبول
وانقره احد الدراسات التي قيمت هذه
الخساره داخل حزب العداله والتنميه النتجه
الى نقطه مفادها ان اداره مساله اللاجئين
من قبل حكومه اردوغان كان احد اسبابها
انهم خسروا هذه المدن الكبرى التي يعاني
بعض اهلها من اللاجئين فيها وبالتالي
انتهج حزب العداله والتنميه في الواقع
خلال السنوات الاربعه والخمسه الماضيه
سياسه دعني اقول ليست مرنه كما كانت
الامور عليه في السابق واتخذ حقيقه العديد
من الخطوات وبدا الحديث بشكل واضح وعلني
عن ما سماه اردوغان بالعوده الطوعيه واي
اشكاليات كثيره بدات يواجهها الكثير من
اللاجئين في استخراج اوراقهم استخراج
الاقامات او التنقل فيما بين المدن وغير
ذلك من الاشكاليات التي كانوا ولازالوا
يواجهون خلال الاربع سنوات الماضيه
كقرارات اتخذت داخل
مجلس الدوله دعنا نقول وبالتالي اعتقد ان
هذه السياسه هي التي سيستمر عليها حزب
العداله والتنميه وبالتالي هي نفس
السياسات التي يمكن ايضا للمعارضه ان
تنتهجها كاقصى ما يمكن من السياسات في هذا
السياق بمعنى ان هناك خطابا غير واقعي عند
كل الاطراف لكن الواقعيه السياسيه دعنا
نقول او الواقعيه الممكنه هو ما ينتهجه
فعليا حزب العداله والتنميه من التضييق
الحاصل الان في الكثير من المناطق التركيه
ولا سيما في المدن الكبرى كاسبول هل تتفق
مع ضيفي عندما يقول بانه هناك واقعيه ولكن
واقعيه قد تكون
حكومه اردوغان في السابق وحسب العداله
والتنميها الحالي هي التي تدفع بها
للتضييق وهذا الملف قد يمثل ملف مهم في
الجوله الثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
تحياتي للجميع في البدايه انا اتفق يعني
مع الجمله تحدث عنها الاستاذ زاهد وخاصه
فيما يتعلق
بموضوع اللاجئين هو كان هناك قرار بعد
الانتخابات البلديه في اسطنبول 2019 في
داخل انقى من صناع القرار بانه هناك اخطاء
ارتكبت خلال السنوات الماضيه بمعنى
الحكومه التركيه تتذكرين في بدايه الاحداث
في سوريا سمحت دخول مئه الف لاجئ سوري
حكومه احمد داوود في تلك الفتره ولكن
سمعنا ان هناك وصل العدد الى ثلاثه مليون
الى 4 مليون ناجا وحتى ان عدد كبير من
المسؤولين منهم من اعمال كورترموش تحدث
يعني قبل سنوات يعني قبل 2019 بانه هناك
حاله من عدم التنظيم وهذه هي سببت يعني
المشاكل ولاحظنا في 2019 و 2020
تصاعد العنصريه والكراهيه داخل الشعب او
الشارع التركي هنا وكانت هي احد الاسباب
التي ادت الى خساره حزب العداله والتن في
انتخابات البلديه في الفتره الاخيره وخاصه
لاحظنا ان الحكومه التركيه وخاصه تتحدث في
مايو 2022 كان هناك خطاب من قبل رئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان فيما يتعلق باعاده مليون لاجئ
سوري الى الداخل
السوري يعني في الشمال السوري وهذا الخطاب
هو يختلف عن خطاب التي سلكتها وانتهجته
المعارضه التركيه خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه بالامس او قبل يومين هناك تصريحات
ايضا مكرره من قبل اردوغان تحدث عن عوده
اللاجئين ولكن سوف تكون هي عوده امنه
وطوعيه وايضا سوف تكون هناك تجهيزات
للبنيه التحتيه تعلمين ان موضوع اللاجئين
هو ليس موضوع فقط دخول وخروج هناك
اتفاقيات دوليه هناك اتفاقيه ابرمت مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي في مارس 2016 يعني حتى
لو جاءت المعارضه وفازت في هذا الانتخابات
لا تستطيع ان تطرد هؤلاء اللاجئين
اللاجئين السوري هنا داخل تركيا هو في
اطار الحمايه المؤقت انا تصوري تصريحات
المعارضه هي انتخابيه استهلاكيه بالدرجه
الاولى ولكن اذا سمحت لي في هذه النقطه ما
بعد الانتخابات واقصد في حال فاز حزب
العداله والتنميه اعتقد الصوره سوف تتغير
بشكل كبير لماذا نتحدث الان ان حاليا
الحلقه القوميه هي فقط بشكل كبير على
الظواهر الانتخابات خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه تحالف الجمهور هناك حزب الحركه
القوميه سنان اوغان سوف نلاحظ ان هناك
تغيير بشكل كبير في وضع السوريين
واللاجئين بشكل عام وخاصه السوريين على
وجه الخصوص بعد نتائج الجوله الثانيه من
انتخابات الرئاسيه صحيح هو حتى تحالف
الجمهور منقسم بخصوص دعم اردوغان من عدم
سنان يدعم اردوغان ولكن هناك بعض الاحزاب
الاخرى حزبان بحسب ما طرح على الاقل في
الاعلام التركي لا يدعمون اردوغان وهنا
سؤال سيتجاهد سنان اوغان الذي يدعم اردو
بمعنى هذه الكتله وفي امامها كلتش دار
اوغلو من من الاطراف لديه الوسيله ولديه
الطريقه ولديه القنوات الدبلوماسيه الاسهل
مع الاطراف المعنيه بموضوع اللاجئين
لتسهيل عودتهم لانه حضرتك تعلم بان عوده
اللاجئين كما تفضل السيد طه عوده يجب ان
تكون هناك قوانين يجب ان يكون هناك تامين
يجب ان يكون هناك قرب من النظام السوري
فمن لديه السهوله اكثر في التعامل مع هذا
الملف
بعيدا عن كلمه السهوله دعنا ناكل من لديه
الوضوح اكثر بالنسبه للشارع التركي في هذا
الخصوص نعم استطيع ان اقول باريحيه تامه
المعارضه لان المعارضه منذ البدايه كانت
تتحدث عن عوده ضروريه لهؤلاء اللاجئين
وكانت هي من تثير هذا الموضوع منذ سنوات
طوال حتى قبل ان تغير حزب العداله
والتنميه سياسته فيه في هذا الموضوع بشكل
واقعي وعملي على الارض وبالتالي هناك
ايمان دعنا نقول في الشارع التركي في اطار
من يستطيع ان يرحل لا اقول من سيرحل فعليا
ولكن من يستطيع او من يريد الترحيل لا شك
ان خطاب المعارضه اقرب الى هذا وحتى
العوده العلاقه مع نظام دمشق
جزء منها يمكن ان نتحدث متعلق بمفهوم عوده
اللاجئين في
العقل السياسي التركي المعارضه منذ اكثر
من عشر سنوات وهي تتحدث ان قطع العلاقه مع
دمشق امر كارثي وامر غير مقبول لان ضمان
عوده اللاجئين لا يمكن الا عبر العلاقه مع
دمشق نفس الكلام الان وبعدها قرابه العشر
سنوات يتحدث به وزير الخارجيه التركي بشكل
واضح وعلى يقول اننا اتفقنا مع دمشق على
ترتيب العوده الامنه للكثير من السوريين
وبالتالي اذا حتى الحكومه خضعت لخطاب
المعارضه دعنا نقول بغض النظر عن ما
سيترتب عليها من افعال وتنفيذ دعنا نقول
على الارض لكن من الواضح ان الحكومه خضعت
لخطابات المعارضه خضعت ويقول البعض بان
المعارضه متقدمه بخطوه على الحكومه لانها
منذ فتره لطالما كانت تدفعها لتحقيق تقارب
بين الحكومه والحكومه السوريه من جهه اخرى
سيد طه هل يمكن ان تنجح المعارضه فيما او
خلينا نقول كلتشدار الان لم نعد نتحدث عن
معارضه وعن حكومه نتحدث عن
هل يمكن ان ينجح
فيما فشل فيه سابقا اردوغان كونه قادر على
ان يطرح اليه حقيقيه بما انه علاقته مثلا
مع الحكومه السوريه افضل او على الاقل دفع
الى تحسينها منذ فتره
قصير او متوسط
لان هناك كان حاليا تعلمين يعني ان النظام
السوري وحتى على الرغم من التطبيع الحاصل
منذ اشهر هناك تصعيد وهناك عقبات من دون
شك هو يعني الدماغ تحاول قدر الامكان ان
يفوز او ترغب بفوز ممكن ان تترتب هذه
الامور وتصبح امور سهله ولكن يعني كما
اشرت لك يعني الامر هو ليس بالامر السهل
معقد للغايه نتحدث عن عوده الملايين
اللاجئين كافه سوف يعودون بطريقه امنه هل
سوف يتم توفير المنطقه
تاهيل المناطق لعودتهم هذا هو السؤال
الاهم هناك مسار طويل ومعقد كذلك كما
يصفها البعض سنبقى في متابعه هذا الموضوع
سيكون موضوع نقاش مستقبلي كذلك
شكر من اسطنبول والكاتب والمحلله السياسي
ومن اسطنبول كذلك زاهد جالي رئيس تحرير
انديب تركي شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات